South African president Cyril ramaphosa
has arrived in the Ukrainian Capital
Kiev as part of an African Peace Mission
ramaphosam and three other African
leaders are expected to meet Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski then going
to travel to Russia for talks with
President Vladimir Putin in Saint
Petersburg on Saturday and follows a
visit to Poland on Thursday we're going
to go live to keep Al jazeer is John
Hull is standing by for us so other
world leaders have tried to find some
sort of solution to all of this and
they've failed so far what is this group
hoping to achieve
well Cyril ramaphosa as you say arrived
in Ukraine by train from Poland in the
last hour or so he's joined by Mackie
Sal the president of Senegal and leaders
and representatives from five other
African countries Congo brazzaville
Zambia
Uganda the comoros and Egypt on as you
say a peace mission to propose what they
described as a series of
confidence-building measures they bring
with them a framework document to put to
the leaders both to Vladimir zellinski
here on Friday and to Vladimir Putin in
Saint Petersburg on Saturday that aims
to encourage the parties to agree it
says to a diplomacy-led process of
negotiations what does that mean well
simply there is no one-size-fits-all
solution being proposed here there are a
series of measures designed to build
trust reduce tensions and most
importantly start a process of dialogue
some of the measures being proposed in
that framework document are Russian
troop pullbacks in certain areas the
removal of the plan to put tactical
nuclear weapons in Belarus they want to
see potentially the suspension of the
implementation of that ICC warrant
against Vladimir Putin and they're
looking at sanctions relief and that's
of course particularly important to
these African countries it means things
like unhindered Ukrainian grain exports
unhindered Russian fertilizer exports
both crucial to African economies in
particular for generating the food they
need to eliminate the threat of Global
Food insecurity Jonah they're only
spending a day in Kiev and then on
Saturday as we mentioned they're going
to meet uh they're traveling to Moscow
presumably to meet Vladimir put I'm
scared sorry Saint Petersburg pardon to
meet Vladimir Putin so they're only
spending a day there Ukraine is in the
middle of a counter-offensive at the
moment how often do we think that
Ukraine might be to all of these efforts
huh
I think you've got to bear in mind first
that Ukraine has been extremely explicit
Vladimir zielinski has said it so many
times that anything less than a plan to
withdraw every single Russian soldier
from every inch of Ukrainian land
including Crimea will fail as the basis
of a peace proposal so on that basis it
looks like a non-starter the other big
issue would be convincing the ukrainians
that these African countries are honest
brokers in particular South Africa
because of allegations recently by the
United States that South Africa has
funneled weapons to Moscow
allegations that the government in South
Africa says it's currently investigating
and also not too long ago Seabourn
drills by the South African Navy
alongside the Russian Navy so there will
have to be some efforts before any
serious talks can get underway to
convince particularly Vladimir zielinski
of honest intent by these leaders Jonah
thank you very much indeed that's Jonah
Hall talking to us from Keith